Nos dicen que "Lulú estaba empacando para un
viaje. Ella puso su ropa dentro de la maleta en
2 filas con 5 blusas en cada fila", así que este
es un dibujo de su maleta abierta, y cada uno de
estos cuadros es una blusa. Podemos ver que hay
1, 2, 3, 4, 5 blusas en la primera fila y luego
otras 5 blusas en la segunda fila. Enseguida nos
preguntan "¿Cuál expresión podríamos usar para
encontrar el número de blusas que Lulú empacó?"
Pausa este video y trata de pensar cuál de estas
expresiones podríamos usar para encontrar el
número total de blusas. Te daré una pista: podría
ser más de una de estas. Vamos a trabajar juntos
en esto. Incluso antes de revisar estas opciones,
podemos mirar aquí y decir que tenemos 5 blusas en
esta primera fila y luego tenemos 5 en la segunda
fila, así que tenemos 2 grupos de 5, de modo
que podemos ver esto como 5 blusas más 5 blusas,
y vemos que esta opción está justo aquí. Ahora,
hay otras formas de ver esto: en lugar de verlo
como 2 grupos de 5, ¿qué pasa si lo vemos como 5
grupos de 2? Este es un grupo de dos, este es otro
grupo de dos, este es un tercer grupo de dos, este
es un cuarto grupo de dos y un quinto grupo de
dos. De modo que podemos verlo como 2 más estos 2
más estos 2 más estos 2 más estos 2, cinco grupos
de dos; o podríamos decir 5 veces 2, que tenemos
justo aquí, así que también me gusta esta opción.